hi this is Alexander Bergen doll with
another video showing up some new
features from our latest update and to
when you launch the game you will notice
a few improvements to the main menu such
as improved readability of the input
options at the bottom of the screen a
new dynamic tile that takes you to the
character customization menu and overall
improve stability and flow in the store
we've added over a dozen new items from
our brand partners as well as a few more
fun items we've also implemented new
character animations in the store that
add a bit more life and movement to the
scene once in game you will immediately
see a new spawn selection camera that
shows more of the spawn area and give
you a better understanding of why the
spawn point is located on the mountain
it is still missing a proper UI but we
think this is much better than our
previous cameras that we implemented in
the last update we've updated and
improved or gameplay camera from all the
feedback we received since the last
updates the camera is now centered again
not too close to the fair and should
give a better sense of speed a new
animation has been added when loading up
a spin which will give you a better
visual cue as to what you are doing
we've added ski trails to the game in
this update we've spent a lot of time
making sure they are lightweight so they
don't cause performance issues you
should see your tracks remain during
long play sessions particle effects are
working again and have been rebuilt to
be more dynamic and realistic now when
you stop or perform a harder turn you
should see some snow spray finally we
have added a real posi- that you stop
using getting confused about respawning
on the mountain
we have begun implementing an event
system and snow this is the first
working version we have and it is
currently quite simple and uses some
debug UI in future updates we will be
adding more events with different goals
we look forward to hearing your feedback
on the steam forums thanks again for
watching